you say Isis Islamic states children
have taken center stage in their latest
propaganda video the new video posted on
social media Tuesday claims to show Isis
fighters cutting off the heads of eight
men said to be Shiite Muslims hostages
were said to be beheaded in the central
Syrian province of ma after young boys
like each hostage into a field before
handing knives to fighters the Syrian
Observatory for Human Rights says that
the video is authentic all right so
we've done a bajillion Isis videos at
this point already and every time we do
one now I have to start the conversation
by saying how desensitized to this stuff
are you at this point like when you see
those pictures are you just like it's
all that land sadly it's super
desensitizing because you they don't
realize like to me it's like the Kevin
Hart effect it's like if you do it too
much if you're around too much I don't
anything that you do anymore because I
see it every day it's like regular
trailer Kevin Hart Kevin Hart Isis video
Kevin Hart just go away for a little
while take six months off come back and
cut off a hair now go oh my god that's
so horrible I mean it's I haven't seen
me yet but you know what now I want to
see I watched all the rest of their
videos yeah
but I'm totally with you on that that
we've seen so much do you guys actually
watch any other beheadings or watch the
guy burning the Jourdain I I am a crazy
person and I did watch the burning video
yeah I've seen worse
I'd really Compton I feel like it's a
like some people like I can't watch it
but I feel like you need to see what
they're doing in order to really really
understand what's happening and as crazy
as it is I think by not saying it makes
it easier for us to detach ourselves
from and ago like I don't really care
what's going on over there I don't know
what yeah so what do you think I don't
watch them and because of that I'm not
desensitized to it
I mean it horrifies me every single it
makes me me it makes me angry like it
doesn't desensitize me to it it makes me
feel like more passionate about what we
should do about right so is that is that
the catch-22 though because on one hand
they put these videos out so that we get
in rage because in a way they want us to
then because then that just that's why
we should bomb that that's why we should
bomb is like like they want their they
have this idea that they're supposed to
the idea is we're suppose they're
supposed to go to us in the fighting
them and we meet them and I think the
beak and it's supposed to be this big
end of the world war right and that's
literally and that's what they want
right so [ __ ] give it to ya we go
there ya meet them there Obama gets on
camera like our WWE wrestler he's like
I'm gonna meet you in the beak and I'm
gonna bring my drone I'm gonna bring my
bombs and we meet there and we [ __ ]
obliterate them and we go back home and
finish house of cards for the day show
and it's not in charge of foreign
problem here's the thing we do meet them
halfway and we do bomb them and their
recruitment efforts go through the
[ __ ] yeah the worst thing that we can
do is give Isis more reason to hate the
West and to get more kind of fundamental
in intensely anti Western Muslims to
join with this
I think that's based on the idea that
you can actually negotiate with these
people and that they're reasonable
people and they're not right you can't
like approach them like reasonable
people like well if we don't attack you
and you won't dare recruit regardless
right so yes propaganda that exists
regardless to think that if we can't try
to empathetically understand where they
are coming from and why their efforts
are the way that they are that we can't
start to understand the psychology of
what it means to be in Isis I think that
the Atlantic article that came out how
long ago was that now maybe a month ago
that really talked about how religious
Isis actually is and tried to put you
know kind of an intellectual face on
that I think was incredibly important
for Americans to understand exactly who
we're dealing with instead of just going
there [ __ ] crazy people no matter
what we do it'll just always be crazy
there's a real reason behind what
they're doing it's not legitimate at all
but it's real and it's there and it's
based on these early religious texts
right so is that the place that we
should be somewhere between neocon like
nothing
right because yeah that's the thing that
I'm a liberal so I stand up for liberal
principles meeting I stand up for women
and Ferguson for minorities so they're
doing horrible things to those groups of
people so I want to stand up for it on
the other hand I'm not a war monger so I
don't just want to attack them and I
feel like that's where most I was before
I got to the just [ __ ] yeah just
[ __ ] get rid of like I spent so much
time like oh let's take this approach
and do this and this is and eventually
you just see this like what are you
gonna do it's so infuriating we're just
like it's easier to just [ __ ] just go
but then using more rationale of why
they do what they do
then what do you do besides do that I
mean I think a part of it is to make
sure that we're working with the
international community to protect the
people who are at risk of being injured
but to protect Syrian citizens to go
into these places where people are you
know and get people out if they are
under Isis rule and help people seek
refuge get them out of the country get
them to the places where they're gonna
be safer granted that's a utopian view
bombing is much but if we can be there
for these refugees I think that that's
incredibly important all right well what
do you guys think bomb um help the
refugees the truth it's probably
somewhere in the middle or something
like that let us know in the comments
right now
[Music]